the shadow defense secretary john healey
joins me now
good morning uh mr healey
good morning
um
does dominic rob's assessment of the
military situation on on the ground uh
seem reasonable given what you know
yes
the russians may have
seriously miscalculated the strength of
the ukrainian military more importantly
they've putin has miscalculated on the
strength of
ukrainian national identity and their
determination to resist in the face of
this
invasion and in the face of putin coming
in and killing people
bombing bombing their cities in a
sovereign state
that russia itself promised under
international law to respect
where do you stand on the ukrainian
appeal for a no-fly zone whether over
the whole of ukraine or as has been
suggested by some people
a limited zone of kiev and the
humanitarian corridors
yes nato has ruled this out and the most
essential thing is that the
western alliance remains together it's
done so because
establishing a
no-fly zone will mean shooting russian
fighters out of the sky
it will do
too little to protect the ukrainians
from the
artillery and missile fire now being
directed into civilian neighborhoods
and
the big risk is that it gives
putin the grounds to rapidly escalate
this conflict
and of course it gives him the get out
of jail free card to explain to his own
people
why his military campaign and his
invasion in ukraine is not going well
i'm i'm going to be talking to a
a
person
on the ground
in ukraine
tell me how i explained to her
uh
why we are not responding because i hear
what you've just said
but from her point of view and i imagine
from president zlensky's point of view
and most of his people this feels like
the west saying
we are happy to support you
except
in order to do the thing that will
really protect you
this is genuinely
deeply deeply disturbing very difficult
um
and
the hard fact is that
well the hard fact is ukraine is not a
member of nato so the collective
security commitments that we have don't
apply but britain has led the way
rightly with labour's full support in
providing the military assistance for
ukrainians to defend themselves when i
was in ukraine in january the ukrainians
were very clear they knew it was their
fight
and they were determined to resist
russia in a way that putin has
miscalculated so the best thing that
britain and
western countries can do at the moment
is to step up the military assistance as
we have been doing to help the
ukrainians defend themselves
support with dominic but
so forgive me do you agree with dominic
rob's skepticism that a cornered kremlin
could step up uh its use of greater and
more unconventional firepower chemical
biological weapons even nuclear weapons
before i answer that i just wanted to
finish what i was saying before because
the other thing that we must do
in maintaining the international
condemnation of russia is also to press
for an immediate
ceasefire and then the withdrawal
of russian troops but importantly and
this is a
job for the united nations to make sure
that we have humanitarian corridors
maintained into these cities under
russian attack in terms of putin putin
we have seen from his record in chechnya
where he
bombed the capital garage knee almost to
the ground and then sent in hit squads
to assassinate individuals that
continued to resist we've seen in syria
we've seen attacks on our own british
soil as well as him seizing the nuclear
power plant in
ukraine how
dangerous this man is and
at the heart of this war
is the danger of escalation
and the discipline and unity from nato
and from the west
in putting in tough sanctions
um and making sure that we reinforce our
nato eastern flank
but saying to putin everything now
depends on you
being willing to negotiate and to start
to de-escalate it's putin that's
escalating and it's putin that must
de-escalate if we're going to find a way
through
this war
that isn't quite an answer to if i may
say it's a question i asked dominic robb
said he thought that all of the
talk about a nuclear alert and so on was
just rhetoric he would not go there do
you agree
well at times of
extreme crisis like this
what
senior political figures say matters
putin has been
used to ramping up rhetoric
he's also been willing to step up
very aggressive
military action as we've seen in other
countries
it should
redouble our determination to support
the ukrainian resistance but also to try
and find a negotiated solution as we
remain united as a western alliance in
saying to russia you may be making
short-term military gains in ukraine but
you will fail in the longer run
you've criticized the government for
being slow on sanctions i talked to
mr
rob about that a moment ago um
what would labour do about uh general
shuy gu or indeed about mr abramovic
neither of whom are on as far as we know
on the uk sanctions list
yeah we've been arguing for some time
for nearly six years since
the scale of the dirty money that helped
keep putin in power washing through
london that action has been required and
for six years we've been arguing for the
economic crime bill that the house of
commons only tomorrow will get to debate
for the first time so the
sanctions that the government has been
willing to put in place the legislation
it's had in order to do so
has been faulty and flawed for too long
and so
that's why kiyostama this morning is
saying to the government look
finally this economic crime bill is
important it will give us some of the
legislative and economic weapons we
don't yet have
but it needs toughening up and if the
government will work with labor to do
that during the passage of this
legislation rapidly through the house of
commons and lords we will give them full
cooperation in doing so
this um invasion has uh forced i think
many people to rethink uh stances that
they've had about things for a long time
sweden
now plans to spend more on defense uh so
does germany um will labor support a
significant increase in the uk's
military spending
well labour backed the big increase in
capital spending the prime minister
announced in late 2020
i would expect to see a big boost to
defence in the budget in two weeks time
the government must
must respond
to increased threats
and increased threats to our security in
europe just as labour did when we were
in government after the 9 11 attacks on
the twin towers
john healey thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning
thank you